hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
a lot of you guys have asked for it a
lot of you guys have suggested in the
comments section that I do it so this is
it without any further ado let's get
started this is just the facts about me
video here are 5 facts about me number
one is I'm a professional athlete what I
know yeah weird so uh you can't really
tell on camera and my videos anyway
unless you maybe watched my CES videos
but I'm 6 foot 3 my wingspan is six foot
seven ish and I played Ultimate Frisbee
professionally technically so if you may
have noticed the jerseys that I've worn
in a couple of my videos in the past
that have some frisbee related things
written on them or a frisbee school that
I go to the team that I play for this is
the professional team that I play for
the New Jersey hammerheads so in the
United States in New Jersey there is a
professional team called the New Jersey
hammerheads that I play for I'm going to
leave their Facebook page down below the
like button on this video so if you've
dumbs up this video and you want to go
check out that Facebook page definitely
give them a like and tell them I sent
you just so that they know that I sent
you I've been playing ultimate frisbee
for well about six seven years now I've
been playing since right after eighth
grade in middle school and I started
playing really competitively I guess in
freshman year of high school and now I'm
in my second year of college but also
get to that in a second but also I play
golf a lot as well on a nine handicap
right now although I haven't played in a
while since it's been really cold but
yeah the two biggest sports I play our
Ultimate Frisbee and golf and
professional Ultimate Frisbee player
yeah
let's go look number two is that I am a
full-time student I am 19 years old and
I am a college student right now a lot
of people surprisingly actually didn't
know this like a lot of people were you
know asking me hey would you like to
work with us on this that and the other
I said I don't really have a lot of time
also I have class today and they're like
wait you're a student so yes I am I'm a
sophomore at a school in New Jersey as
well and I'm majoring right now in
Business and Technology if you're
wondering what I'm studying and I'm also
studying a lot of information systems
and marketing and similar things to what
I do here on my youtube channel but yeah
I'm a full time student so a lot of the
things you can see I have going on
restrict the amount of time I have for
other things so a lot of time spent in
school which means that YouTube videos
have their own time and Ultimate Frisbee
has its own time and golf has its own
time so yeah I don't sleep at all right
number three is that I have a really big
soft spot for red and black things as
far as long as I can remember you know I
don't really know why but the
combination of red and black is
absolutely my favorite colors and any
product that happens to use red and
black in them I tend to have a soft spot
for it whether it's a car or just a
small gadget or something like that if
it has red and black I'm going to
consider it because I really like that
also my lucky number is 82 I don't
really know if that has to do with
anything but yeah red and black things
tend to get my attention really easily
so if you want to sell me something if
you have red black option that's
probably a good way to get me to buy it
number four I used to be a huge huge
huge anti desktop person yeah I know you
thought I was going to say but I used to
be a huge anti desktop person I would
never even touch I wouldn't even
consider buying a desktop I ran all of
the things that I did for a very long
time out of my laptop I guess I say very
long time for me I mean I'm 19 so that's
only a couple years but yeah for the
longest time I had a desktop computer
originally and then I decided that was a
terrible idea and I went straight to a
laptop and this was my setup for a while
my full-time setup and this was before I
was making YouTube videos at all and it
was an HP pavilion dv4 tube video on
and I was like my full-time rig you had
eight gigs of RAM I really like max that
thing out pretty much everything I could
fit in it I put in it I started making
videos on my laptop and I actually added
another display so this was my just my
full-time setup for my laptop slash
desktop it's almost you would what you
would call a desktop replacement laptop
meaning it doesn't really ever leave
your desktop but it's not actually a
desktop so it was a 17 inch screen I
think it was 1680 by 1050 it was a it
was a decent machine that I maxed out
and yeah for the longest time I just
didn't ever consider desktops of course
when I started doing more intensive
video editing and things like that I had
to I had to pick a desktop oh and
finally the number five fact is that I
am a huge music person not music making
but music listening that is pretty much
how I get through my day I'm not allowed
or boisterous person I don't talk a lot
but I definitely listen to a lot of
music it helps me do homework it helps
me get through things and yeah so I
listen to music all the time and ever
since I picked up the j-bird blue buds x
wireless earbuds they're these Bluetooth
wireless earbuds that I've been using I
haven't left the house without them I
listen to them on my way to class and on
my way back from class every day they're
really awesome and speaking of house I
know I said the word house in there
somewhere but speaking of house that's
the genre of music that I guess I listen
to the most house music along with other
electronic based genres I have a
playlist and Spotify with more than 250
songs of just house music and yes I'll
do a lot of house here are some of my
favorite songs throughout time I've had
a lot of like all-time favorites these
are some of them so I'll have the links
in the description so if you want to
check them out there they're the DJ
remix by madyun really good alive
binders remix push and rise and America
by Wolfgang Gartner and I think Wolfgang
Gartner is my favorite music artist of
all time
lost at sea by Z human after all by Daft
Punk and easy by Mat Zo and Porter
Robinson and me and you by Nero so those
are some of my Keystone favorite songs
of all time through a couple of years so
yeah there you go guys those are 5 facts
about me 5 personal facts about me I
know a couple of other youtubers like I
said have done
so props to them for doing that and
getting the the idea to do this video
and also to your comments for telling me
to do this video but some bonus facts I
guess that are just just things that I
feel like mentioning number one my first
smartphone ever was the LG Voyager and
that was at a time when it was literally
iPhone versus everything every new
smartphone that came out it was deemed
the iPhone killer it was Willis thing
beat the iPhone or not and I wasn't on
AT&T when that thing was 18 t exclusive
so I got the LG Voyager because I was on
Verizon another fun fact after the first
100 videos that I made on the mkbhd
channel I had 78 subscribers now I tell
people this and they don't really
believe me because they see the way the
channel looks now and it's kind of hard
to believe but yeah after 100 videos I
had 78 subscribers so if you guys are
you know reeling over the fact that no
one's watching your videos and you've
made 50 videos and you have 50
subscribers that's probably a really
good sign it's been I don't know a long
time since I started I started making
YouTube videos in January 2009 so it's
been a while but just a tip for you guys
if you guys are starting making videos
don't get impatient don't get don't get
down about it just make videos about
things you love and people who love the
things that you love making videos about
will find you and last thing for those
of you who are new to the channel or for
those of you who don't already know
mkbhd is what I go by because it's a lot
shorter than marques Brownlee but mkbhd
stands for marques K Brownlee High
Definition because I like pixels Andrew
you will never get my middle name thank
you for watching guys I hope you enjoyed
this again quick video if you are
interested in any other quick facts
about me or if you have any questions
feel free to leave them in the comments
section below that like button and you
might find some other interesting facts
about me that you didn't know before so
there you go thanks for watching and
talk to you guys in next one hey